Speaker 1: All right.
There's something very interesting happening
within the Republican Party, as we've talked
about before, and that is this growing civil
war not only between anti-Trump and pro-Trump
Republicans, but as I've said before, now,
a couple of times between formerly pro-Trump
Republicans and pro-Trump Republicans and
Donald Trump has now shown us the pinnacle
of his vindictive nature.
His rage at anyone who might levy even the
mildest criticism against him, he has completely
turned on Republican Senator Lindsey Graham.
Now let's kind of build up to it.
The context here is that Donald Trump has
now floated that he might pardon Jan. six
rioters if he becomes president again in 2024.
So here is Trump saying that for the first
time at his rally in Conroe, Texas, over the
weekend, here's a reminder
Speaker 4: how many people have been asking
me about it.
If I run and if I win, we will treat those
people from January six fairly.
We will treat them fairly.
And if it requires pardons, we will give them
pardons because they are being treated so
unfairly.
Speaker 1: So after that, which is a dangerous,
outrageous statement after that.
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham appeared
in a TV interview.
Lindsey Graham is a longtime friend of Trump's.
Lindsey Graham is a guy who played golf with
Trump regularly during the presidency.
Got along.
You know what?
To whatever degree Trump has friends, Lindsey
Graham would be considered or would have been
considered a friend of Donald Trump and Lindsey
Graham says it's completely inappropriate
to do that.
And it seems like it sort of might be encouraging
the exact type of violent destruction of of
the capital that we saw on January six.
Here is Lindsey responding to Donald Trump
talking about pardons.
Speaker 2: Pardons.
Do you agree?
Speaker 5: Yeah.
No.
I don't want to send any signal that it was
OK to defile or capital.
There are other groups with causes that may
want to go down to the violent path that these
people get pardoned.
But isn't that a dangerous thing to say?
Harris Yeah, yeah.
Well, I think it's inappropriate.
I don't want to reinforce that the following
the Capitol was OK.
Speaker 1: OK, so Trump is asked about this
during a Newsmax interview yesterday with
Rob Schmidt, and he completely turns on Lindsey
Graham.
He calls Lindsey Graham a RINO, meaning a
Republican in name only.
And you really see here this disloyal, vindictive
Trump that is the guy we know exists, obviously.
But here it's coming up with a guy who was,
in theory, a friend of Donald Trump's take
a look.
Speaker 3: You talked about the potential
if it's appropriate of pardoning some of the
Jan. six.
Yeah.
Lindsey Graham said a couple of days later,
he thinks that's inappropriate.
Speaker 4: What do you think?
Well, Lindsey Graham is wrong.
I mean, Lindsey's a nice guy, but he's here
right now.
Lindsey is wrong.
Speaker 1: Look, this is really the kind of
bottom of the barrel disloyal Trump.
There's no loyalty for Trump, his best friends
again, to the extent he has real friends,
and I don't know if he does.
Trump's relationships with people, including
his own family, are very, very strange.
His friends are immediately enemies if they
say just one wrong thing.
Graham is just the latest victim here, Trump
going on to talk about how many of the rioters
are not even guilty.
He says that they're patriots.
Some of them, they're not guilty of crimes
and says Lindsey Graham doesn't know what
the hell he's talking about.
And this is notable for a couple of reasons
which we'll talk about in a moment.
Speaker 4: And some of these people are not
guilty.
Many of these people are not guilty what they've
done to to these and in many cases, patriots,
their soldiers, their policemen, what they've
done to them compared to what they've done
to the other side.
Speaker 1: Now, by the way, the fact that
sometimes they're soldiers and police.
And that's an aggravating factor.
These these are folks that we should be saying,
wow, if soldiers and policemen are so diluted
that they're doing this, it's not even about
criminality.
We should be questioning whether they should
be soldiers and policemen.
For Trump, it's oh, but I mean, they're soldiers
and policemen.
They just shouldn't even be charged, I guess.
Speaker 4: You know, you have to have equal
justice and this is an equal.
So I would absolutely be prepared.
And Lindsey Graham doesn't know what the hell
he's talking about.
If he says that because you have to have equal
justice, it's very, very unfair what's happened
to this group of people?
Speaker 1: Now, if you claim to be for law
and order and due process, how can you say
someone is not guilty before their case has
even been adjudicated by the legal system?
They don't care about any of their principles.
How many times have I said this now?
They're about law and order.
When it's convenient, they're about due process,
when it's convenient.
Prisons and jails are places where we don't
have to concern ourselves with conditions
when it's not there, people who are there
now, all of a sudden Trump and others are
saying the conditions in jail that these people
are being held in are terrible.
We've been talking about that for decades.
We've been talking about it for decades.
And then the attacks on it, rather than the
issue of sentences, comes up again here and
Trump saying restating that he is up for giving
pardons.
Speaker 4: Some of them are being treated
very unfairly.
Yeah.
I would absolutely give them a pardon.
The punishment should work out fairly.
Speaker 3: Punishments are out of proportion
to the crime out of
Speaker 4: proportion, like 20 times out of
proportion.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, if there are if if
they're patriots, the way Donald Trump said,
why on earth would they get any punishment?
So this is extraordinarily dangerous and this
is a hallmark of the fascist dictator.
The dictator want to be the authoritarian
and the autocrat, right?
Wherever you want on that scale.
Friend of the show, former guest fellow Argentinean
Federico Finkelstein, has been tweeting a
lot about this when law and order don't work
for you.
What authoritarians and fascist dictators
do is they impose their will instead of law
and order.
And that's what Trump is saying.
Here we are.
You've got to do everything right.
You can come to the country, but you've got
to do it legally.
You everything just legally.
The way the law says, Well, here we have people
who are being subjected to what the law says.
No, no, no, no, no.
My will that these are patriots is what now
matters, and I will pardon them if given the
opportunity, it doesn't even matter whether
he really would pardon them.
It's impossible to know that at this point
in time.
One last clip from this interview.
Here is the reporter.
I mean this this guy should.
He should really be blushing from this interview.
Here's the reporter Rob Schmitt sort of praying
at the altar of Trump and saying, you know,
you could be having such a great life, but
instead you want to be president again.
It's truly unbelievable.
Speaker 3: It has got to do stuff as much
as you do.
I mean, most people by your age just want
to relax.
Speaker 1: You want to go back in.
What a hero.
Instead of just relaxing, Trump wants to go
back in war zone.
Speaker 3: I mean, you're flirting with it
right now.
You're not going to announce and I understand
that.
But to go back into there, I think people
would have to say, you're crazy.
Speaker 4: Very simple reason.
We have a great country that's going to hell
and it's going to hell very fast and we're
not going to have a country left.
Speaker 1: And this is the same rhetoric from
2016.
We don't we're not going to have a country
great job.
Speaker 4: I did more than most presidents
would do in 30 years between the taxes, more
damage, the regulations and the business and
everything he did
Speaker 1: with the business.
I mean, think about how meaningless these
things are.
He did the taxes.
You OK?
Yes, there was a tax bill passed.
He did the regulations of no meaning and he
did the business.
Speaker 4: Then I got we got hit with the
COVID rate from China and they got to pay
something for that.
They're going to pay something that nobody
could afford.
You know, it's probably 60 trillion dollars
worldwide.
Speaker 1: Anyway, I want subjected to more
of it, but a truly delusional interview showing
us the vindictive nature of Trump, the childish
and jealous nature of Trump, and also his
complete and total willingness to do absolutely
anything and complete abandonment of his stated
principles.
In this case, law order and due process when
it doesn't work out the way he wants it to
work out.
Extremely dangerous stuff.